(Putting on boots)
Let’s… go for a walk.
And let’s slow things down a bit. And take noticeof the world right beneath our feet.
In these miniature environments, vast dramas unfold,
often without us ever realizing it. But what
if we could become part of these sagas? In
the Pikmin series, you play as a character
under two centimeters tall, and experience
a tiny yet rich ecosystem from the ground
level. And though the Pikmin universe is more
stylized than some, its surprisingly complex
lore makes it ideal for study. So, let’s shrink
down, and see the world from a new perspective…
In a flash of light, our ship arrives planetside.
This is world PNF-404 — though we would know it as
planet Earth. But this is not the Earth of
today. Humanity is gone, and in its place,
strange new orders of life have emerged.
We are a very tiny explorer from a distant
planet. It is our job to catalogue this world —
a daunting task, considering its many dangers.
Fortunately, we are not alone in our
endeavor. This is a Pikmin. A Red Pikmin,
specifically. These friendly local lifeforms will
help us uncover the mysteries of this planet. But
what are Pikmin? It’s a question we can’t answer
right away, for their biology is so bizarre, it
will take time to formulate a theory. Let’s start
with what we do know about Pikmin. Pikmin work
together. Like ants or termites, they’re eusocial
— able to divide up their labor to benefit the
whole. While one group of Pikmin is defending from
a predator, another might be collecting resources,
or even building a simple structure. We also
know that Pikmin are unusually strong, able
to carry objects much larger than their bodies.
Ants are capable of similar feats of impressive
strength relative to their size. Where Pikmin
differ from familiar forms of life is in their
reproduction. Pikmin are ‘born’ from a strange,
globular plant nicknamed an Onion. The Onion will
periodically release seeds into the air, which
develop underground into adult Pikmin. It’s such
an unusual process that we’ll need to know more
about their world before we can understand it.
The first region we’ve landed in is the
Sun-Speckled Terrace. Lit by gentle, dappled rays,
this area seems peaceful at a glance. But there
are many hungry mouths here. These are Bulborbs.
A member of the Grub-Dog family, Bulborbs come
in all shapes and sizes, but are united in their
bottomless appetites. One of the most successful
orders on the planet, Bulborbs have conquered all
manner of environments, and filled all manner
of niches. The peculiar Whiptongue Bulborb,
for example, has a feeding method similar to an
anteater — able to slurp up multiple targets with
its long, sticky tongue. We are fortunate to have
Pikmin on our side to help keep these beasts at
bay. But Bulborbs are far from the only danger.
These are Fiery Blowhogs: creatures with poor
manners and hot tempers. When threatened, they can
expel a volatile phosphorus compound from their
snouts, which combusts immediately upon contact
with air. This is where Red Pikmin come in handy,
as flame-proof cellulose in their skin
makes them heat-resistant. All the same,
it’s best we give Blowhogs… a wide berth. More
extreme lifeforms await us underground. In the old
caverns beneath the terrace, unique subterranean
species have emerged, like the Snowy Blowhogs.
Unlike their fiery relatives, they prefer to
cool things down instead of heating them up,
able to expel a compound similar to dry ice from
an internal cold sac. Tusked Blowhogs forgo the
complex chemistry of their siblings altogether, in
favor of the simpler strategy of running headfirst
into prey. These caves are also home to the
unpleasant Sheargrubs, creatures that emerge
from the ground in droves. Like Pikmin, there are
many specialized types of Sheargrubs — with some
possessing wings, and others long snouts ideal
for spearing prey. And they have a nasty habit of
swarming. To a human sized lifeform, these insects
would be little threat. But this is a world for
the bugs now. Back on the surface, Flint Beetles
— descendants of modern beetles — and Spectralids
– descendants of butterflies, thrive in large
numbers. From our new, scaled-down perspective,
these familiar species have a newfound grandeur.
It is often our viewpoint that defines our
surroundings. The Sun-Speckled Terrace seems to be
the remains of a small garden, but navigating it
feels like crossing a vast, mountainous terrain.
It made me think more about my own perspective.
…There’s a creek near the place where I grew
up. I went for a walk there the other day,
and as I walked, I stopped at random points and
stuck my camera on the ground. It was… awkward
at first. But it made me realize something.
There are… a lot of bugs out there. And yeah,
everyone knows there’s lots of bugs out there — I
knew there’s lots of bugs out there. And yet… it
still felt so different to actually see them all.
I passed so many bugs in the first few minutes,
it made me wonder how many hidden worlds I walk
past every day… Like the Blossoming Arcadia,
another microecosystem in Pikmin. It appears
to be the remains of an old playground,
but like the Terrace, this ordinary place
becomes a perilous expanse due to our tiny
lens. Fortunately, the Yellow Pikmin are here
to give us a helping hand. Their bodies are
naturally resistant to electric currents, able
to withstand shocks like certain species of
catfish. And it’s a good thing too, because
many species in the Arcadia pack a serious,
electrical punch. This unusual specimen is a
Bearded Amprat. Though nonthreatening when calm,
these territorial creatures will sometimes
rub the hair on their face to generate a
formidable electric field. The Yellow Pikmin,
however, are unimpressed by the voltage.
Leaves fall in more peaceful regions of the
playground. But bump into certain leaves,
and you might be surprised. These are Skitter
Leaves, creatures that panic and live up to their
name when poked. Because they often camouflage in
a group, waking one Skitter Leaf can start a chain
reaction that causes the entire colony to panic.
Perhaps it’s kindest to simply watch our step.
A species that will not extend this courtesy
to us is the Yellow Wollyhop. A rather rotund
member of the Amphituber family, they possess
the rather rude instinct to crush smaller
lifeforms. We’ll have to move fast to stay
alive. Fortunately, we can catch a ride on
a furry companion. This is Oatchi. A loyal canine
seemingly distantly related to the dogs of Earth;
we don’t know much about his biology. But I
really like Oatchi. Oatchi is a very good boy.
I’m less fond of the Waddlequaff. These feathered
lifeforms use their overdeveloped respiratory
muscles to suck in large volumes of air through
their beaks. An effective method of feeding,
if a frustrating one to be on the other end
of. But it’s better than facing down the spear
of a Joustmite. A burrowing insect, Joustmites
are quite proficient at spearing anything that
disturbs their slumber clean through — including
multiple targets should the need arise. It’s a
behavior similar to the Swooping Snitchbug, who
will snatch up multiple Pikmin and burrow them
back in the ground. And if these fluttering pests
aren’t enough to demonstrate the newfound might
of insects, the bioelectric Anode Beetles of the
caves certainly are. These insects can connect
with each other to create a discharge too powerful
to withstand. Only our trusty Yellow Pikmin are
up for the task. But there are some challenges
even Yellow Pikmin are not up for. These hopping
fledglings are Downy Snagrets, and probably don’t
seem like a significant threat. But they are only
babies — and their parent is close by. From the
ground emerges a colossal Burrowing Snagret. This
bird has converged upon the niche of an ambush
predator. Their mobility and sheer size make
them the tyrant rulers of the Blossoming Arcadia.
Perhaps this region simply isn’t worth the risk.
Maybe we’ll have better luck on the coast.
Based on the name alone, the Serene Shores
seem quite peaceful. There’s just one problem.
Ordinary Pikmin can’t swim. We’re going to need
some kind of specialist. The Blue Pikmin
will be the perfect lifeguards. Thanks to
a mouth-like gill membrane, these Pikmin can
breathe underwater — and are ready to tussle
with all manner of aquatic life. They’re
the ideal allies for this watery ecosystem.
Skimming on top of the water is a graceful
Skeeterskate. Likely descended from pond skaters,
Skeeterskates use hydrophobic hairs on their feet
to remain on top of the water. They store water in
a sac atop their heads, which they’ll regurgitate
if we get too close. But it’s better to be spit at
than eaten whole. Water Dumples are unassuming
purple blobs with ravenous appetites. Their
behavior makes more sense when you consider their
closest relative is the terrestrial Bulborb. Yet
their appetite seems almost quaint compared to the
Peckish Aristocrab. While these crustaceans begin
their life as tiny nuisances, they soon grow into
full sized, intertidal terrors. An unfortunate
creature for those who enjoy long walks on the
beach. And Aristocrabs aren’t the only crustacean
to look out for. Hermit Crawmads are ambush
hunters that will rush at sources of movement
from their burrow, before awkwardly wobbling back
underground. A descendent of the hermit crab,
Crawmads have lost their shells entirely, and as
a result are not the bravest creatures here on the
coast. If a Crawmad fails in their initial attack,
they will often shamefully scuttle away in defeat.
Other ambush predators have a less subtle,
but far more destructive approach. Armored
Cannon Larva will regurgitate large stones from
their gullet to flatten enemies. They feed on
minerals to support the bacteria in their gut — a
behavior analogous to certain types of shipworms
that consume limestone for the same reason. A
questionable diet, but an unquestionably effective
offensive tactic. Not every animal on the Serene
Shores is quite so hostile. Puckering Blinnows are
relatively peaceful creatures that swim in schools
beneath the surface. Pearly Clamclamps are another
seemingly calm semi-aquatic species. But trigger
their snapping mechanism, and you’ll find there’s
more to these clams than meets the eye. Clamclamps
are the ultimate patient hunters, using their
pearls as bait to ensnare unlucky prey. They’re
proof some treasures… just aren’t worth it.
There’s a region of the Serene Shores that
appears to be an abandoned aquarium. Here,
you can encounter Jellyfloats, strange
floating lifeforms that can hover,
likely due to some internal gas bladder. Yet while
one’s focus should definitely remain on these
giant floating predators, when I encounter them, I
keep thinking about the surrounding aquarium, how
uncanny it is that an ecosystem has formed around
this abandoned place. I have a similar experience
facing down the Crusted Rumpup. The apex predator
of its environment, this giant has poor eyesight,
and charges blindly at any potential meal. Not
a creature to face while distracted. Yet while
evading this goliath, I found myself once again
transfixed by the surroundings. The Rumpup seems
to make its home in an abandoned sandcastle.
Like the aquarium, here, the remnants of the
past define the present. The same can be said
for most of the environments in this game — the
shape of each ecosystem determined by junk
humanity left behind without a second thought.
The landscape of the creek from my childhood is
marked by similar relics. Plastic caps and broken
bottles lie on the banks. I did my best to clean
up the area, although more trash will certainly
come. The creek itself isn’t even a natural stream
— it’s all runoff from a drainage pipe. Human
overflow changes the shape of micro-environments
like this one all the time, despite most people
not even knowing they exist. Nowhere in Pikmin
is humanity’s influence more present than the
next region, which takes place entirely within
an abandoned human home — a unique ecosystem
with unique life. The mighty Purple Pikmin are
going to be of particular help here, as man-made
obstacles can be crushed under their considerable
bulk. On the floor of the household, strange
creatures teeter about. These oddities are called
Breadbugs, and live up to their names with bodies
that resemble, well, bread. Breadbugs can be seen
dragging shiny objects to safe locations, perhaps
due to some nesting instinct. The real mystery,
however, is why any species would evolve to
look like a common food item? The Giant Breadbug
subspecies looks even more like a delectable loaf,
deepening the mystery. Considering that camouflage
is typically a strategy to avoid getting eaten,
it is probable that the Breadbugs
resemblance to food is just a coincidence.
Another culinary creature oozes across the
floor. The Sunsquish resembles a fried egg,
yet is actually a kind of protochordate, a type
of invertebrate. Though carnivorous, this is one
egg that’s not too difficult to scramble. But
you’re the one more likely to get scrambled if
you start a fight with a Mammoth Snootwacker.
This species sports a tough exterior shell to
deter predators. But if they still don’t get the
message, the Snootwacker can wind up their trunks
for a devastating strike. When a species asks for
privacy, it’s best to respect their wishes. In the
plumbing systems below this house, a secondary
ecosystem thrives. This environment is home to
creatures like the Pricklepuff, a pufferfish-like
animal with toxic spines. Luckily, Ice Pikmin can
help keep us from needing to get our feet wet.
These Pikmin can freeze bodies of water, creating
a walkable surface. In-game scientists assume th
ese creatures are made entirely of ice. I think
it’s more likely they have biological components
that let them expel a freezing chemical mixture
much like a Snowy Blowhog, although we still need
to learn more about Pikmin in general to formulate
a proper hypothesis regarding their biology. With
Ice Pikmin in hand, we’ll make the acquaintance of
the Hydro Dweevil. These crab-like insects have a
natural instinct to hide under human objects. The
emergence of such a behavior across all Dweevil
subspecies speaks to the impact humanity’s debris
has had on evolutionary processes. But other
creatures carry things for a more sinister
reason. The Gildemandwee possess a sweet-smelling,
crystalline growth on their back to attract prey.
And while juvenile Gildemandwees have a somewhat
limited appetite, the adult Gildemander is
prepared to ask for seconds. The vast growths on
their back combined with the angler-fish lights
on their heads mean that even the wariest
prey can be pulled in by their display.
Yet there is one species so wary, not even a
Gildemander could entice it. Although that doesn’t
mean this cautious creature is defenseless. The
Scorchcake is one of the stranger lifeforms of
the Pikmin world. These molten disks might
not look like an animal at all, but they
are actually a type of mollusk — a connection
that is more readily apparent when they extend
their periscopic stalk eyes. Scorchcakes create
bursts of fire through oils secreted from their
shells — a strategy similar to the Pyroclasmic
Slooch, a species of terrestrial snail that
might be the Scorchcake’s close relative. Though
Sloochs have abandoned the shells of their cousin,
they flash bright colors to ward off any predator
not deterred by their scorching trail. Perhaps
the most well defended creature of all is the
Porquillion. These spiny goliaths are among the
most formidable creatures in this entire region,
able to fire off spines at an alarming rate. If a
Porquillion runs out, however, they must retreat
until their spikes are able to regrow. Such a
process expends considerable energy, and means the
Porquillion is always searching for its next meal.
Since we don’t want that to be us, we’ll try
our luck in the backyard, a region known as
Giant’s Hearth. And right away, it’s clear that
this area is the wrong locale to seek sanctuary.
Bulbears are Bulborb relatives that are even more
aggressive than their cousins. We’ll need some
particularly tough Pikmin to brave this ecosystem.
And it’s difficult to get tougher than a Rock
Pikmin. These stony fellows are so strong, they
can burst directly through crystalline walls. But
how does an organism made of stone function? In
game text suggests the Rock Pikmin’s hard exterior
is actually just an outer shell of inorganic
material that a smaller lifeform exists within.
And when you consider that many modern organisms
have shells made of rock-hard calcium carbonate,
such an adaptation doesn’t seem so far-fetched.
A tough shell won’t do you much good against
a Bloomcap Bloyster. These hungry mollusks
constantly probe with their feeding tendrils.
Their smaller cousins, the Toady Bloysters,
seem less threatening at a glance. But looks
can be deceiving. This is one species that
has changed radically from its ancestors.
Other organisms have changed little over the
eons. Arachnodes are spider descendants that
remain just as skilled as their ancestors,
able to sense food at any point in their webs.
Underground, little understood arthropods called
Shutterchucks collect shiny crystals. These
crystals have useful properties, and Winged Pikmin
will help us transport them. They may be small,
but Winged Pikmin are deceptively strong. This
doesn’t seem impossible considering bees can haul
up to 91 percent of their bodyweight in nectar
alone — yet it does show that the world of Pikmin
still holds many secrets. Deeper underground, we
can at least answer the mystery of where Bulborbs
come from. They appear to begin their life as tiny
larvae, utterly defenseless without an adult. But
an adult is close by. This is an Empress Bulbax,
a Grub-Dog with a massively enlarged egg sac for
bearing children like the queen of an ant colony.
When threatened, this monarch will try to crush
opponents with its sheer bulk — rolling directly
over them. But left to her own devices, the
Empress Bulbax prefers to peacefully snooze. In
fact, most of the creatures in this game seem calm
until the player stumbles by. …I loved looking
under rocks as a child, getting a glimpse of the
insects in their natural state. Except… I wasn’t
seeing them in their natural state, not really — I
was seeing their panic mode after their home had
been disrupted. To get nature to do what I wanted,
I acted less like an observer, and more like an
instigator. And the same thing happens when you
play Pikmin. You might have noticed throughout
this video that lots of creatures require a treat
to motivate them into doing something interesting
for the camera. You’re not really connecting with
the ecosystem; you’re more pushing it into doing
what you want. Of course, sometimes, the ecosystem
pushes back. Explore at night, and we’ll find
familiar locations made eerie and unsettling,
and animals becoming more aggressive. Your
only hope is to make an alliance with the
mysterious Glow Pikmin, who seem to be ghosts.
Like, the in-game encyclopedia implies they’re
straight up ghosts. So, I don’t know how their
biology works, I got nothing. The night sections
are another grave reminder that there’s still
much about this ecosystem we don’t understand.
I found footprints by the creek the last time I
went. And while this made me feel like a tracker,
the truth is I don’t know what kind of animal they
belong to. I feel the same way in Pikmin when I
encounter something like the Mamuta — a strange,
hairy creature that doesn’t fit with the other
animals I’ve encountered. Other than the fact it
likes to plant Pikmin, I know nothing about its
biology or lineage. Perhaps the final region has
some answers. The Primordial Thicket is a vast
undergrowth teeming with life more dangerous than
any other area. Dense networks of fungi coat the
forest floor, and thick clouds of spores can block
certain pathways. The tiny White Pikmin can help
thanks to their natural immunity to the spores’
toxins. Indeed, these spores seem to be parasitic,
as they’ve overtaken the bodies of many animals
that live here. And this — at last — provides key
potential insight into the mysteries of Pikmin
biology. Many of the animals in this forest seem
to be a combination of both fungus and animal.
In some cases, like that of the well-camouflaged
Startle Spore, the fungal parasites seem to
be an integral part of their biology. And the
Startle Spore has a cousin, in the form of
the more plant-like Creeping Chrysanthemum.
And something about how the Chrysanthemum
emerges from the ground seems awfully familiar.
More on that in a moment… One species that seems
immune to the fungal network is the towering
Grubchucker. These bipedal creatures snag prey
with the long reach of their pincers and toss them
into the mouth on top of their heads. The food is
then digested slowly — a fate we want to avoid.
We must also avoid cloudy water, for the
Bogswallow lies in wait. Possessing six
primitive eyes, these creatures seem to be
a holdover from a forgotten primeval age.
Yet the last new creature we’ll visit today is far
more ancient, and mighty. It’s a Sovereign Bulbax,
the largest member of the Grub-Dog family.
These genuine titans snag food with their long,
sticky tongues, and can swallow up many unwary
Pikmin. Notably, the Sovereign Bulbax cultivate
a rich carpet of plant matter on their backs that
helps them stay camouflaged under the ground. It’s
another example of plant and animal symbiosis that
might finally let us crack our big mystery… Given
all we’ve seen, the Pikmin may be . . . hybrids
of animals and plants — specifically, parasitic
plants like the Creeping Chrysanthemum. There’s
evidence to support this, as some explorers are
turned into plant hybrids after exposure to an
onion. If this is correct, Pikmin have clearly
evolved to become heavily intertwined with their
plant partners. Indeed, one in-game scientist
proposes that Pikmin are entirely plants, and
evolved from root vegetables. And while this
seems… less likely, as is often the case with
Pikmin, it’s impossible to say for certain.
Though the time has come to leave this particular
world behind, it’s worth reflecting on our new
perspective and the mysteries that remain.
Pikmin isn’t a series that reveals all
its secrets. Like a child turning over rocks,
you’ll always be an interloper to some extent,
an outsider making assumptions. But it’s a
series that makes you think more about the
ecosystems just below you. And I’ve left plenty
of stones unturned and creatures undocumented
if you’re interested in exploring this world
yourself. And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious. See you in the next video.